all right doctor
let's hear a story the sirens of time I
am taking kind of a head-on plunge into
the world of Doctor Who audio around the
same time that I'm working on getting
caught up on a classic Doctor Who so in
addition to those reviews of classic who
you'll start intermittently getting
these of audio ones I have no set order
that I'm doing this in I have tried to
start with you know some of the earlier
ones I've made a point for now of doing
ones that are stand-alones and now it
looks like a lot of the more recent
stuff is like it's in four parts or it's
that continuous thing over over stories
or there's like an ongoing background
I'm not touching any of that I'm dealing
with self-contained stories and I
decided to start with the sirens of time
now I'm going to really try to avoid
talking spoilers in this because I don't
think it's safe for me to assume that
people watching this review have already
seen it the way that I can usually
assume people have with episodes of news
certainly or even classic to a certain
extent so I'm really gonna be not as
plot specific with a lot of the things
I'm talking about so this is I'm gonna
try and rein in my normal rambling just
touching on everything things a little
bit in terms of a broad story on this
it's kind of got an interesting
structure because it's it's very clearly
broken into four segments each buffered
with you know the music comes in so it
is broken up like it's four episodes
it's a total of two hours so the first
one deals with the Seventh Doctor the
second one deals with the fifth doctor
and the third one then deals with the
sixth doctor they are each and a
different place and time dealing with a
different thing sort of ends on a
cliffhanger for all three of them and
then all three come together for the
fourth one which resolves everything and
explains what the heck was going on up
to this point anything that's the first
thing I don't know how many of these are
sort of structured as a mystery we're
not sure what's going
on thing but there there is a part of me
that like would would have kind of like
to have had a few more strands to grasp
on to because it really does feel like
for three-quarters of this story you
barely know what's going on not in a way
that's necessarily confusing but just a
sort of in a we're more than halfway
through the story and I'd literally know
no more than I did at the start of this
way it kind of adds up over a while it's
the sort of thing that you don't think
about as much if you like sit down and
listen mmm start to finish I did have to
break up my listening of it and having
time in between each episodes it did
kind of bother me a little bit more and
again it's not bad I think I think in a
lot of ways my early reviews of these
are going to include maybe not
necessarily criticisms but maybe a
slightly dampened enthusiasm because I'm
still kind of getting used to this like
I haven't grown up on audio dramas as a
thing so it's not a medium I'm used to
like the closest I come to it is
listening to podcasts but I don't listen
to narrative podcasts so I I'm I'm not
used to sort of listening you know
getting used to identifying characters
who I haven't heard before and and you
know hearing for the certain certain
cues of this or that or now there's this
and or you know just focusing just on
extent because generally when I'm
listening to something I'm doing
something else at the same time and
that's and that's all on me that's not a
criticism of this but I'm just kind of
explaining that I'm probably going to
take a couple of stories to get fully a
climate a climate 'add to the experience
of taking and Doctor Who this way as far
as the doctors we get obviously
Sylvester McCoy Peter Davison and Colin
Baker all voiced fair incarnations of
the doctor and already even though he is
not the focus of all this already I am
hearing how Colin Baker works better and
audio than he did on the show there's a
couple of reasons the first is he's got
a layer of charm in his performance here
that was largely absent from his time of
the doctor and that was always a big
part of why he didn't work for me in the
show which was that you know he was
arrogant and pushy and impatient he was
all these things that other doctors had
been but when the doctor was all those
other somewhat grating things before he
was also usually charming in addition to
that so it kind of got away with it
Colin Baker wasn't charming on the show
he is kind of charming in the audio so
that takes the curse off it a little a
little bit and then I think the
additional thing is I have to look at
that outfit and I will always understand
what the theory behind that outfit was
you know contrasting you know his darker
persona with this crazy sort of colorful
look I get the idea but it was it was
such an eyesore and it was always
distracting so not having to look at
that and just hear his performance and
just get to focus on that much more and
not get distracted by that freaking coat
that goes a long way and I'm not like
suddenly now going ah Colin Baker's my
favorite he's got a way to work before
he can get there but even just his part
in this one audio I can go okay yeah I
see where people say that he really
works on the three I actually think he
kind of works the best
McCoy is probably the least impressive
of the three and he's not bad I think
the thing is though his doctor you know
is always very I almost said maniacal
Marc availa Nellie and that's the word I
was looking for you know he's always
he's working a plan he'd so the
situation that this story puts him in
where he's very off the if he's off
balance and doesn't know what's going on
so vested that doesn't bring the best
out of Sylvester McCoy doctor that's not
to say his doctor can't work in stories
like that but when you put him in the
same story as the Peter Davison doctor
or the Colin Baker doctor who do clearly
work better in that sort of environment
where and that kind of story
he becomes the weak link a little bit
again he's not bad but I mean there's
three doctors there I'm gonna kind of go
and compare them a little bit as far as
the story itself goes it's it's pretty
good I mean the ideas are nifty it's got
a nice bit of tiny Y meanness which is
nice I don't always expect that of who
in basically pre-new who I knew it I
know we do it from time to time and even
some of the classic episodes did it but
usually it didn't the the show and again
my experience largely is the show didn't
delve too heavily into the possibilities
of all the time manipulation and stuff
it did so occasionally and this sort of
dips into that pretty well the other
vocal performances are pretty good
there's some interesting notions about
cause and effect and in terms of finding
out what we find out about the villains
that's interesting I was a little bit
iffy on the conclusion insofar as it it
reminded me to a certain degree of
Revelation of the Daleks which is a
Colin Baker story that I don't like but
the reason I don't like it is because
the doctor it almost feels like he
shouldn't be there in that story like
there's a conflict between Davros and
and this other guy in like the Daleks
are involved but like all that resolves
would have the doctor being there and
like he doesn't impact was actually
going on at all it's a big part of why I
don't like that story this isn't quite
that it doesn't hit that level but by
the end you do it does sort of lay out
these two forces that are at odds with
each other and the doctors just kind of
caught in the middle he does still
actually impact the story they pack the
way it turns out so it's miles better
than revelations of the Daleks but to a
certain extent he did feel a little bit
not passive passage the wrong work I
mean he's active and he's doing stuff
but he didn't feel as vital to the story
as I may be personally would've liked to
that said the final resolution and how
things fully resolved did some nice
things in terms of contrasting how the
different incarnations of the doctor
behaved and kind of how he feels about
himself at times so it didn't dwell on
that too much it could have gotten
heavy-handed so it was a nice note and
so when I mentioned these things that
I'm like kind of not nothing do you
railed the thing they were just sort of
little dip like oh that's
okay but then it pulls it together and
and it was largely okay so I it
certainly doesn't leave me feeling go oh
god I just wasted a ton of money buying
all these audio dramas no I liked it I
enjoyed it apparently written by
Nicholas Briggs who I know for voicing
Daleks and Cybermen and apparently he's
a big deal at a big finish I think a
fair number the ones I bought are either
written by or directed by him or both
so that's that's my thought on the
sirens of time worth checking out there
if you're a continuity hound there are
some things that are inconsistent with
stuff that has happened since then like
just to cite something that isn't a
spoiler like the TARDIS doesn't have the
telepathic field where anyone within a
certain radius of it can all just
understand each other that isn't a thing
yet but it hadn't become a thing in like
the continuity of Doctor Who yes so if
you can accept that certain things that
this does are kind of contradicted later
on and yeah I think you do have to kind
of accept that the audios are not
necessarily 100% canon you kind of have
to take them as their own thing so if
you can make that kind of roll with it
and if you can be used to the format
like I said I I'm I'm still getting used
to it is worth checking out I enjoyed it
so those are my thoughts on the sirens
of time have you heard it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on Apple podcast as well as
stitcher radio I'm also one half of the
punch like a girl podcast that is a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network Fire and Water podcast
comm links for all this stuff is gonna
be down below in the description and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]